everybody it's jeff from the overwatch
team again happy to be doing another one
of these developer updates we thought
we'd take a different angle this time
and talk a little bit about what's
coming up after the holiday break for us
and a little bit of why you know what
we're doing is going to be relevant so
just to back up a little bit we've heard
a lot of requests for some sort of
progression or reward system in the game
and it's something we're very eager to
get to and sort of the irony some of you
know that some of you don't but the
irony is that we've actually had to
progression and reward systems in
overwatch already and we've cut them
completely they were total failures so I
thought one of the things that might be
interesting is to tell you guys a little
bit about what we did in the past and
why it failed so you'll know when we get
to our new system next year why we sort
of went in the direction that we did so
the first system that we tried was
really interesting it was very similar
to like a WoW talent system or heroes of
the storm talent system where you would
customize your hero so what would happen
is you would play somebody let's say
like Reaper and level Reaper up and as
you leveled up we would unlock different
abilities for you to take and then you
go into combat and you'd be able to do
different things with Reaper so one of
the examples we had is when he went into
Wraith form he would heal to full so I
know some of you are probably shocked
like wow that sounds super powerful and
broken and imbalanced and like I said we
scrapped the system for that reason
basically what we were learning about
overwatch early on was as much as
everybody has this fantasy of I want to
customize my character in terms of
gameplay overwatch plays and moves very
quickly and there's a lot of information
to sort of take into an into account if
you look at a game like heroes of the
storm sometimes you know you only have
to worry about five heroes at once
knowing what they do or who they are and
what their abilities are or in a
worst-case scenario in a game like
here's the storm you only really have to
no 10 heroes max what's going on in
overwatch you have to have every hero
that could possibly be in the game in
your mind in a much faster match length
so suddenly having two different Reapers
on the battlefield and maybe one is
healing to full when he does Wraith form
and the other has double distance with
his shotguns was very confusing for
players and very overwhelming so we
scrapped the system we also felt that
just player power in general through a
progression system especially when there
was some time investment involved was
not good for the competitive nature of
overwatch so that was system number one
that failed and we took out we talked
about it a little bit at blizzcon in
2014 for those of you that remember then
we went down another path and when I
describe this to you're going to say in
hindsight like of course that's obvious
you know you guys should have never put
in in there in the first place but it
wasn't really obvious to us until we had
put the system in and felt it so the
second system we explored had nothing to
do with player power we wanted to focus
entirely on cosmetic rewards which I'll
touch on a little bit later but what we
did was we created a system where each
hero had a level there was a like a
level / hero and the more you played
matches the more you would level up and
winds were worth more exp than losses
and there was you know certain ways to
gain more exp and as you leveled up a
hero like let's take tracer for example
maybe at level 2 you would unlock some
cosmetic stuff and then at level 3 you'd
unlock more and so on and the heroes
capped out at level 20 in the system it
was cool and it was fun but we we had
this live in the in the blizzard alpha
where all of the employees of Blizzard
were playing the game and immediately it
went south on us very quickly so we
would have these cases of you'd be
playing on temple of Anubis and your
team is pinned down in the sandcrawler
you know you can't even get out of Santa
crawler and you look at over at one of
your teammates and they're playing
Bastion you know they're sieged up
inside the spawn room shooting
the door and very politely tell the
person you know hey dude maybe we should
switch to a class that can get through
the choke and and that person would
they'd even be really reasonable about
like yeah you're totally right it's not
right for the team that I'm on Bastion
right now but I'm so close to my next
unlock I don't want to switch off so the
system turned out to be I would describe
it as a minor disaster the cool part
that came out of it was we came up with
a lot of really compelling cosmetic
stuff that like we had really good
rewards for it that the blizzard
employees were very excited about and
I'm going to leave some of those a
little bit of a mystery for you because
I'd rather you see them in person some
of them there's already been hints out
on the internet like people you know
data mined the build and they saw stuff
like our sprays which I think are really
cool there are these awesome emblems
that you can unlock and you know you can
put them actually in the 3d space in the
level sort of show off things that you
had done so those were part of the
system but we had a lot of other really
really cool stuff as part of that but we
realized that the system was encouraging
the wrong behavior in a game that's
about fluid team composition and hero
swapping that a system that overly
rewarded you sticking on one character
was just bad and wrong so what we want
to do when we we've now taken the game
down it's no longer up the beta is going
to come back hopefully mid-january too
late January if the game's not in a
state that we're happy with it might
take even longer than that we might
spill into februari if needed but what
we want to do is introduce a new
progression system that doesn't overly
reward people hanging on one hero like
sometimes it's okay to reward that
behavior we know that there's a lot of
you who have your main and you really
enjoy playing that one character and we
don't want you to feel bad or wrong
about doing that either but we also
don't want to overly reward that's that
type of thing with a progression or
reward system I had a really interesting
conversation with tom chilton who is the
game director on world of war
craft and he made some awesome points
when talking about progression and
overwatch we were talking about World of
Warcraft Diablo and overwatch and Tom
sort of said you know in games like Oh
world of warcraft and diablo in a lot of
ways those games are about progression
you know whether it be through the
character leveling the character power
or the item acquisition it's the main
motivating factor but unless your game
is inherently about progression you want
to be careful to make sure not to overly
focus players on progression as the
end-all be-all and that's how we feel
about overwatch we feel like we would
like the progression system to be light
cosmetic and almost the way of the game
thanking you for your time in it saying
like hey that's cool we know you've
invested some time in overwatch so we
want to give you these light rewards
that don't overly skew the way that you
play the game in one way or another your
motivation for playing overwatch should
be that it's a fun competitive
multiplayer shooter or not that you're
trying to get more powerful or require a
bunch of items so we're probably going
to take a different route with the
overwatch progression system when we get
back to it we're going to use the time
off we already have ideas of what we
want to try and we're going to use the
time between now and end of January to
explore a bunch of stuff internally
again because we'll learn a lot very
quickly just you know trying ideas out
in the game seeing how they come to
fruition and then if we feel really good
about them then we'll bring the beta
back up and we'll introduce the system
to you guys so I look forward to
hopefully next time talking in more
specifics about what we are doing but I
thought it would be helpful for you to
understand you know why why we're
exploring these different routes with
progression and what sort of went wrong
in the past so when you see the new
system you understand how we got there
anyway thanks as always for all the
feedback and comments we'd love to hear
what you guys think about rewards what
you guys think about progression systems
and we really
hope that you guys have a great winter
break and we'll see you soon probably in
January
you
you
you